thank you for coming back enjoy the show
it's about to start momentarily please
do consider joining mug club at laterthe
credit calm slash mug club for
additional content to support the show
because we're not monetized on here and
if not just bookmark the page check in
every day we have a new video that goes
up every weeknight at 9:00 p.m. Eastern
also Crowder bits there's another
YouTube channel where you can find
sketches I think this is gonna be a good
one I have no I watch for yourself about
that for a teaser lauder with Crowder
studios protected exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
face it head higher than Afghanistan you
call improv
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
like beer
hi
[Music]
I know wait
brogre Margit
[Music]
only play and a failing heart how about
that my social this
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is called the please Alice Cooper
don't copyright on the show they with
Ben Shapiro Oh we'll be talking about
student loans quick announced but there
will be no live show next Thursday does
everyone know why yeah boom it is going
to be our annual live Oscar stream party
yeah every ninth on Sunday 7:45 p.m.
Eastern please don't strike us yes or as
we I refer to it
hurricane x oh yes oh we're in tornado
time zone you're in hurricane time zone
we have on the program of course my
official Republican I guess great glad
to be well that was a very saw the flip
of the pen and eyes the white of the
eyes go Morgan
we've got immortal immortal Cabernet
like immortal technique yeah wonderful
underground rap oh I see that my
underground hip-hop references are lost
I mean the apologetics professor okay do
you support the idea of forgiving all
student debt why or why not
sustained why or why not
okay why do you support and then
ultimately who do you think pays the
bill if we forgive all student debt is
there an actual victim in the equation
who could it be we've talked about this
a lot this whole idea of victim culture
sometimes creates actual unintended
victims we'll get to that in a second
but first now is the time on ladder with
crowder where we dance
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish I loved anything as much as he
loves being a sex criminal Oh what the
hell are we watching you sign on the
ride and purchase a ticket
Gerald you don't like the video of
yourself let's wait we have to lull him
into a state of complacency Hillary
Clinton has admitted that she now feels
quote the urge to run against President
Trump mm-hmm
adding that she thinks she can win
because quote the 2016 election was a
really odd time also having the urge for
the run again Donald Trump pretty much
yes actually upon hearing the story
President Trump decided to include his
thoughts when drafting up his upcoming
State of the Union yeah and that is
where you could stick your articles of a
Peach Pit
as for my opponents frankly so many
losers at the bright side at least I
don't have to run against Hillary
Clinton if she would enjoy the race now
truthfully there is no way I would kick
her ass in the next dimension there's no
way it would be a nightmare for Hillary
Clinton to throw her hat into the rig
for 2020 it would be the single worst
thing that could happen to me also I
don't care what your mind says folks she
is that a rapidly aging murderous crowd
a / angry closeted lesbian in turn to be
a little less loose with the quote maybe
the more research yes but when reach for
official comment Bill Clinton said
anything that gets the [ __ ] out of the
house and then you proceeded to have sex
with women other than his wife
Oh a Tuesday for how great their calling
card
this was embarrassing and I know what
happened at the beginning of the week we
talked about those weren't mug Club
members uh behind the paywall some
wonderful programming by the way going
to mug club in blaze here soon big
announcements why didn't anyone tell me
that my hair was doing the Clark Kent
I'm so embarrassed
that's exactly the same anyway just like
your shirt wait repeat sir
Gerald is just a hobo this this was
really embarrassing it happened earlier
in the week but there's a little more
context or an MSNBC anchor allisonmorse
claims that she said nay hers okay and
not the n-word while reporting on and
here's a clip reporting on Kobe Bryant's
death it seems like he was just the kind
of athlete the kind of star that was
perfectly cast on the Los Angeles Lakers
I've heard she was trying to say no
Lakers but no team has a G in their name
[Laughter]
yeah the Nuggets Linsanity dude she took
a pause to she heard a cake makers and
it happened by obvious she claimed
mixing Knicks and Lakers now on the
surface listen this is an understandable
mistake though some have pointed to
Allison's other slip-ups from referring
to them as the Toronto wraps
to the Chicago Blackhawks as well as
where she burned crosses on the lawns of
every active member of the Detroit
Pistons Roger it's a flood that one
seems pretty cut and dry yeah seems hard
to deny yeah a lot of evidence just put
it all together I give her a pass oh
really
first when I saw it when I reviewed that
I was like no no it needs to be the
MSNBC anchor not pink in the spirit of
consistency I don't I think this woman
made a mistake I don't think that she's
a racist I don't think that we should
crucify this woman but do you think that
an apology if this happened on Fox News
would be enough of course not they'd be
out there I know so but we don't want to
we don't want to live but still be
hearing about it in science news so
let's talk about science oh good
cannabis and right now the common hold
it so cannabis might actually just save
global bee population whatever
the leaf desk I don't know if that's a
[Music]
no
scientists believe hemp has a potential
to provide a critical nutritional
resource that could help reverse our bee
shortage which lets you know this is
this is incredible let's make this to
increase medical research in other
fields and sadly it actually proved to
be unhelpful in researching be allergies
let's pray the fourth time we've
referenced that film that is taking
something that is incredibly painful to
travel um I guess just reappropriation
it so that you can laugh it's like you
know hip-hop artists do with the n-word
it's the white version of that wait
reappropriation Geralt isn't in no I'm
not because I'll get no apparently the
Grammys were on Sunday I didn't really
pay attention we're prepping on nobody
big Oscars dream next Sunday February
9th the singer Chris Brown brought his
five-year-old daughter with him that was
all over yeah that's right and during
the course of the whole evening he only
hit her once so you have to take the
wins
oh that's lower than his average the
progress yeah hey you know what's a
downward trend yeah I'd like to see that
the Compu strike from that limo ride to
get the Compu strike right and some
punches just bob and weave Chris
international news our Ugandan you
gained an imam he's he's actually up
he's been suspended from his duties of
the cleric after his wife of two weeks
turned out to be a man really male the
wife was arrested for the theft of a
television set and when a police officer
carried out a body search found it
wasn't actually a woman so
some are speculating that this was all
part of a big plot to embarrass the
high-profile Imam with some other people
having chalked it up to just a simple
mistake others are still circulating
rumors that this was simply an elaborate
plot to promote the new Wayans brothers
vehicle Imam chicks so that seems most
that's not them he has the faces swapped
to the wrong Wayans brothers wrong was
the other way are they brothers way in
there okay they're brothers Wayne not
named Damon so finally there was a
recent study actually that came out we
thought this was interesting and by the
way a portion of this was written before
news this week which will be relevant
when you see it I apologize we can show
you yeah the document that it was
drafted three weeks ago but we just
couldn't pull it at this point recent
study claims that women are actually
being held back in marketing
particularly the marketing field by a
persistent pervasive sexism the arc
article says so sexism in the marketing
field listen at first we were all a
little bit skeptical but having looked
into it they they may be onto something
gentlemen and the seminar you will learn
everything you need to know about sales
and marketing so take notes set aside
all your Don Draper bolt and listen
closing let's take a look at this logo
coca-cola one of the most successful
logos of all time why do people love it
anyway the red and the white draws the
eye yeah and I think I'm the curse if
writing is classic but it still feels no
restaurant and remarks like that or
exactly what Julia left you Hey Hey look
at me look at me hey who's your fault
hey hey hey it was your fault
moving on people love this logo because
it looks like a penis
it's clear now let's take a look at
another logo the Nike logo famous simple
sleek yes it's a penis next logo NASA
it's keep cycling through these the YMCA
Toyota Lexus Amazon the NBA all penises
the New England Patriots Facebook
BuzzFeed Motel 6
ow d Puma the Miami Heat NBC there are
several going here
SpaceX beats by dre Oldsmobile Jaguar
the sci-fi channel Ferrari the e Network
the Royal Bank of Scotland you've got
four penises st. Louis Cardinals
Gatorade Brooks shoes
VLC Saucony in-and-out burger Chili's
the Washington Wizards PlayStation the
old Reebok logo the Cleveland Cavaliers
Asics Pontiac Arby's the Orlando Magic
Volvo Tesla the Dish Network USB and
finally Kobe Bryant's signature Nikes
now it should be clear that the link
between all of these is that people want
products because people want penises do
we have any questions well what about
the the air B&B logo it it kind of looks
like a vagina
talking about penises here Carl get your
mind out of the gutter disgusting
you know
karl karl has a point written before
this week yes yes there were some people
he won't live to answer it's like six
people you know who worker and every
heard and go home yeah collective sigh
but i was some of those are a little bit
of a reach little sure no the cavaliers
looks like aggressive penetration yeah
that's what amateurs called the oil
check look it up understand the terminal
you know what let's just mr. block
competitors do it because they're
cowardly so let's talk about student
loans i know a lot of people were Bernie
supporters and now kind of Trump
supporters because you're
anti-establishment I understand that we
want you around but a lot of them still
support this idea of forgiving off
student loans
and I understand why it sounds good on
its surface I would like to hear your
opinions before you watch this segment
let me know if it may be change at all
let's start with this Elizabeth Warren
was recently questioned by a dad
regarding student loans and having put
his daughter through college
compare that to Ted Cruz when he was in
Iowa when he was talking about corn
subsidies and the scenario so you're
gonna hurt our industry here and he
explained to the guy by the end of it
the guy intersted the corn somebody's
might actually be bad for his farm yes
imagine if it's come back your spin no
laughing right that's the better way the
constituents face hey I saved for a long
time I'm the American dream I have a
family I put my daughter through college
I can't buy your vote handed him a card
that says I laugh you prick you
patriarchal paternalistic prick that's
what she said that was a subtext yeah
that's right after the clip and in
creating a new victim class and right
now the victim class extends to people
who willingly took on student loans so
I'm getting loose with the terms here we
create real victims who might the real
victims be like this father or people
like folks who work here on this team
who worked two three jobs to pay their
way through through school or went to
community colleges or went to trade
school or some people who work here who
actually didn't go to university and
instead gained workplace experience and
worked their way up those are the actual
victims because they will be double
footing the bill they saved their money
right they avoided the student loans or
they paid off their own student loans
and now you're asking them to pay your
student loans it's understand how it
seems compassionate in people
hey these folks are saddled with debt
and we'll get into that in a second and
why that's not necessarily accurate even
let's assume that student loans and it's
predatory lending it's the bank's fault
it still wouldn't solve the issue in
forcing somebody else to pay that bill
twice okay so let's go through this idea
though the crisis because it's a
predicate on the idea that there's a
crisis right now this is a huge claim
you see from current Democrats that
there's 1.4 trillion in student debt
right $35,000 on average per individual
I think
we have a clip on this welcome back to
Velshi arul senator Bernie Sanders is
joining others in Congress to unveil a
sweeping new plan to Dwane eliminations
put questions this proposal completely
eliminates student debt in this country
and ends the absurdity of sentencing an
entire generation the millennial
generation to a lifetime for the crime
of doing the right thing the 1.5
trillion in student loan debt and this
time we're gonna choose our people right
Philadelphia
what do you mean sours people to
questions why is Andrew yang wearing his
hat up like Ernest goes to can drive and
second any more transparent with his
pandering our generation the Millennials
what about boomers this year Millennials
who undoubtedly will vote for me this is
something that's important to note it
sounds like a lot 1.4 trillion it's not
nothing
car loan debt in this country is about
1.2 trillion dollars and carts
appreciate way faster than education
unless of course it's a gender studies
degree in which case depreciate you 100
percent once you roll your fat angry
feminist ass off the lot how is it
compassionate let's say let's say
quarterblack garrett okay has some car
payments left hey audio way do you have
any kind of you know i bought an old
used car cash okay and i say hey you
know what Wade and I pull out this gun
hey Garrett's car payments you know what
a nice guy
I didn't pay the car payment right I
just forced way to do it why is one
compassion and one is not let's go out
we'll talk about car payments mortgage
loan debt by the way that comes in at an
average of over $200,000 per person
that's nine point five trillion dollars
Josh why isn't that considered a crisis
according to Bernie Sanders but and so
correct me if I'm wrong but the 35 year
on dollars thank you thank you sir may I
have another
man $35,000 thank you sound like yet a
low interest doesn't sound like crushing
debt for an individual I know I
understand it's early in their earning
career and everything else but am I am I
the only person here that's like $35,000
doesn't sound like I don't have a mouth
there's an underwater basket-weaving
with my tarantula is help them out right
you know here's a quick lesson for you
and people got mad at this week if you
want everyone out there okay Uncle
Stevens taken care of if you want to
build wealth
don't buy a new car ever right and to
other people if you want to go green
right you want to be environmentalist
don't buy a new car let's just say ever
it is better for you to buy an old 85
Bronco than that new Tesla it has to be
created and driven off the lot so that
you can have your rich white liberal
guilt status symbol but they're so fast
don't fight a new car there's no reason
for you to unless you're a
multi-millionaire and you're just
looking to throw money around and you
hate the environment fine but this is
you don't have to buy new cars Leo or
Daymond you can buy used cars and they
don't yeah so what I find is really
interesting this example of like don't
buy a new car is the same example of
well I mean the only thing I can do is
go to a four-year institution that's
$50,000 a year and have the government
you know approve these loans and then
I'm gonna sign this paperwork but now I
really don't know what the paperwork
said and oh you mean I have to pay it
back later at some point I mean the
whole point here is if you're gonna do Y
shopping the the other core layer of
what that father was saying is what
about the the kid who decided to go to a
JUCO and said or a community college
instead paid for it themselves and their
five years out and their some amount of
years behind someone who took loans out
and it's just gonna get it all for free
you're actually doing a persistence of
right the the difference between those
people and you're punishing those who
worked harder and is that that said did
it the right way well I just don't know
if someone always has to pay the bill
it's like they deal with health care in
pre-existing conditions what you're
doing is now you've astronomically
raised healthcare costs right we're
talking about Brian Eames deductibles
that's because people who opted and by
the way most people who didn't have
health insurance chose not to have
health insurance when we crunch the
numbers so you can go back and search
that segment they could afford health
insurance particularly young people they
opted not to until they had a serious
condition well the whole point to buying
health care insurance is it's basically
creating a
pool of lower-risk so that you can use
it when you need it so the people who
bought health insurance before the
emergency arose that's why they locked
in lower rates then had to pay a higher
bill because everyone else who didn't
have that kind of forethought is now
joining into the same pool it ends up
harming people who've thought ahead who
planned responsibly not always some
people get some tough breaks by the way
tough break notifications don't really
work you have to hit the notification
bell all modifications because thank you
YouTube and please do consider joining
up at lot of credit come slash mug Club
mug club you get everything that is
available on place TV and this wonderful
NH mugging like 19 more shows of this
per week okay exactly
it's 478 here's another point that we
need to get feels like um if we're
talking about who it harms who does or
who would rather a student loan
forgiveness who would that reward right
Bernie Sanders actually uses this term
he just talked about use of the term
punishing I believe right now we should
stop punishing people for going to
school we have a clip bottom line is we
should not be punishing people for
getting a higher education it is time to
hit the reset button under the proposal
that we introduced today all student
debt would be canceled in six months
well you know what Bernie maybe you
should be punished for being a lifelong
unemployed couchsurfing ass who's never
been gainfully employed aside from
suckling at the government's teat maybe
you a little bit forgiving student debt
it punishes those who worked hard and
everyone into that like we've talked
about the Iowa debt but who does it
reward ok people think that if we
forgive student loans and this is
something again I understand why people
think it's compassionate but the numbers
do matter they think that most of this
money is going to go to those who have a
hard time paying off their loans right
that's how Bernie presents it right a
ton of that would go to people who are
making a lot of money anyway so yes the
average will come back to that student
debt is around thirty five thousand
dollars but let's look at how its
distributed I think we have it let's
look at a chart we have it right here
most of the people if you look fall on
the low end of that spectrum well below
thirty thousand yeah and then you have
students with astronomical costs rightly
stretch things out on the opposite end
of the spectrum so those on the high end
you see in this chart typically come
from families making over a hundred and
fourteen thousand dollars a year and
they go into careers like law and
dentist
so it takes some time to pay off those
loans but they're actually living pretty
comfortably a huge or I should say a
huge portion of these large numbers that
are being cited it's actually evidence
of a crisis that is somewhat created by
upper-class families who take out loans
to put their kids into very lucrative
career paths I mean how much is law
school I mean it can range anywhere from
if you're at certain state programs
twenty thousand a year to fifty or sixty
thousand a year all told with expenses
so right exactly but you're not going to
be destitute if you go into law probably
not but I would actually say that
there's an issue when it comes to grad
school because a lot of folks will say
you know whether it's a liberal arts
program or you know a Gender Studies PhD
or even a a JD or a Gender Studies now
oh yeah Wentworth and there is again did
you decide you're gonna go do this thing
and who's gonna have to pay for you
having to gone and got this degree right
is it gonna be right the rest of the
loan pairs gonna be the rest of America
if you decide to forgive the loans for
people who are just going to grad school
for no purpose or no reason right then
you're literally asking someone else to
subside your education I followed maybe
about half of that because in my head I
was just thinking I have an annuity JG
Wentworth mu JG put a hit out on mr.
Wentworth no no I love my lawyers
this will be removed and rightfully so
there's going to be some guy who's named
J / D Wentworth who's going to get
horrible emails and about her substance
in his mailbox and he's gonna find this
video we're very sorry our bad it's the
other G by the way you have problems
paying off their loans it's actually a
pretty small group they tend to have
people who actually have a hard time
paying off the loans being settled by
debt tends to be less than $5,000 when
you eliminate people who are going to
medical law school yeah where they have
a lot of student debt initially and they
pay it off quickly people who long-term
have problems paying it $5,000 that's a
number that matters
so let's before we go to the idea of
federal government what could be a
personal solution for you
right is there a silver lining yeah
there is it doesn't require any federal
intervention okay so here are the steps
you can take number one go to a
reasonable college or trade school okay
then number two choose a major
discipline that'll set you up for a well
paying job number three finish your
degree that's it that's it finish your
degree
statistically you'll be absolutely fine
again those people who have that debt if
$5,000 hard temping most them don't
finish yeah absolutely and obviously if
you don't finish you don't get to use
the benefits of having that degree to
make more money so finish but bill
brought this up go to the Community
College for two years who says that you
have to go for those first two years
where you're getting your basic right
out of the way nobody cares if you
transferred from a community college and
then graduated from UT your diploma says
UT right as a matter yes cheaper than oh
and this is actually a good but this
brings me to point number three everyone
out that you should consider trade
suppose trade schools have a ton of
advantages over four-year colleges on
average by the way I'm about 70 percent
less debt twice the job placement almost
twice the starting salary right we have
it we have it up as a side by side Yeah
right here so I can actually read it
yeah average debt 36,000 at a four-year
college we just went through those
numbers job placement about 50 percent
average debt ten thousand dollars for
two year trade school 100 percent
average job placement was almost twice
the starting salary but again we we
market this idea of the college
experience which for many is four years
of glorified alcoholism certainly for
going there don't forget the victory lap
if they go for five mostly like this you
don't need to do it and this does come
from a lot of intellectuals a lot of
politicians who place this value on an
elite university that is not reflected
in real world
I've had parents be horrified when Kim's
come up at live shows until you give my
son ru advice I said well what do you
want to do and if they say I want to be
a fireman or no it's great do it they
say I don't know yet I said don't go to
university have debt yeah it's kind of
pitched as the thing that you do after
high school like some summer camp that
you go to and have a great time no
you're not going to work harder than you
worked in high school to try to have a
career and be able to provide for
yourself that's what you should be
prepared well and I think it's very
important too we're talking about going
to university or whether you go to trade
school do choose your major wisely okay
this is another kind of solution that
you can all take into account here or
not and then ask Bernie to take my money
to bail you out fine
but think about how you make any other
purchases right you just go out and buy
the most expensive car you can afford do
you go out and you buy the most
expensive house you can afford no
financial advisor would say that's what
you should do come out that is exactly
what we do with universities we tell
kids apply to all of the top schools
meaning the most expensive the most
prestigious schools that's usually what
parents tell their kids to see which one
takes you in and if we look at
University Rankings based on economic
value added to students lives not their
status symbol not how many people see
the the the crest on your jacket right
yeah but how much value would actually
adds to students lives here we can look
at the metrics actually with these
numbers look at average student salaries
the employment rate if students are
employed in their particular field of
studies according to that metric many of
the top colleges they're just public
universities in state schools yeah
basically unless you're planning on
going to the Supreme Court you don't
need an Ivy League university to be at
the top of your field people in the top
of any of these given fields there is no
no correlation between a specific school
or degree from that school and success
now if you know exactly what you want to
do let's say practice law or you host a
podcast where you want to tell everyone
that you practice law
[Laughter]
his wife good doctor go ahead what I
really find this interesting is think
about who are the people that are being
rewarded you're rewarding the people who
didn't take personal responsibility in
making those choices but you're also
rewarding the universities right so
think about what the framework when we
talk about the first amendment we said
hey when there's hate speech we don't
need to have more regulation
we already regulate dangerous speech or
you know inciting violence of those
types of things in other you know
calling amazing and murder and
cold-blood JD wentworth yeah yeah but
but we already have a framework in place
you're going to become a parable do you
know but you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater a call for the
assassination of duty white birthright
he's a national hero it's fine okay but
what we already have evergreen worst in
place to deal with any type of fraud
that may have happened in that horse of
selling these universities laws because
think about if if the loan companies had
sold you to bill of goods about the
loans themselves well i didn't know i
had to repay it right then okay you have
a lawsuit there if the university sold
you and you didn't get the education you
expected you have another lawsuit there
if you were misled by your parents just
put them in a home or don't talk to them
or don't go to is in steadies new year
must and Lunar New Year solstice ISM
team if you're going if you're who are
you going to reward you're gonna reward
all of the people that created this
system instead of you know you want to
punish someone punish the people who put
us into the system if they deserve
punishment yeah or the people who didn't
take Andrew yang to his credits talked
about how some somehow maybe cost should
be tied to those fields of education and
if you look at majors like I think it's
education like art he hid art history
ethnic studies things like that you know
things that are kind of useless that you
can learn on Google and two afternoons
they're not high earning fields right
but they require a comparable amount of
student loan debt right on the other end
the majors that have the highest
earnings to debt ratio are stem degrees
right which is science technology
engineering
mathematics masters in humanities from
Stanford is like having a brand new
Maserati in your driveway it's a it's a
modern status symbol and it costs you a
lot of money for a piece of money yes
your Maserati mother all Maseratis no
Maserati sponsorship here no competitor
also BMW just take me off your list I
don't like your cars I'm not gonna
happen yeah this goes back to if you
have a clear plan of what you're
majoring what the best school is for you
I don't I don't want to discourage you
you should shoot for that absolutely but
keep in mind twenty to fifty percent of
students they enter school is undecided
and then most of them not so most of
them end up changing their major again
step one you want to fix go to
reasonable school step two don't major
in worthless [ __ ]
step three finish your degree and you
will avoid this problem yeah and one of
the things that I think is lost in all
of the discussion about this is why do
we have so much student debt right now
why is tuition skyrocketing and there's
there's a couple of statistics out there
that are really telling the Federal
Reserve Bank of New York said that every
one dollar in federal aid actually
increases tuition by sixty five cents
right you're essentially creating the
same bubble that we had with housing
yeah I'm just doing it for student loans
and then Bernie Elizabeth Warren you
guys want to go back to who caused to
this they actually trace it back to a
1978 a bill that passed in the Carter
Administration that basically guaranteed
all of these loans so that people could
go out there and get them so easily but
it didn't matter anymore if you
qualified or if you could actually
afford to pay it battle that was helpful
and informative and I appreciate that
you you slipped a Carter jab in there I
did yeah well earned
it's well-earned there are a lot of
people who are allergic to tree nuts
that's true what look fix the problem
don't just try to take care of a symptom
of the problem right the actual problem
well think about this for us this is
really and we do have to go to a Ben
Shapiro in a little bit this is a
brilliant ploy right you tell people
young people Millennials as Bernie
Sanders said his voting base you tell
them that they are the victim of some
predatory system of lending right you
encourage them to saddle themselves with
more debt in attending universities that
they can't afford often pursuing degrees
that guarantee all but guarantee an
inability to pay off that debt not to
mention by the way you're incur
young people to make arguably the
largest financial decision of their
lives before they graduate high school
because they're already applying you
further encourage you further
incentivize this behavior with grants
and scholarships from the government
like you said which also leads to two
simultaneously hyper inflates right the
cost of education overall and then you
bribe the voters who followed your
instructions explicitly by promising to
bail them out with other people's money
and this is something I hear a lot you
hear people's and well why shouldn't we
bail us since we bailed out the banks
how about we bail out nothing how about
we don't bail out Goldman Sachs or the
Afro lesbian Studies major you hear
these songs they hit their do any
politics that you hear on the right as
well and while they're living it up on
Wall Street they're shutting Detroit
down shut them both down shut all of it
down I'm not looking for as a Bear
Stearns Goldman Sachs Bear Stearns their
Stern theirs which there's bear and
there's bull correct
Bear Stearns interbank bear market bull
market you can see I don't know
economics I just make it rain but we
should not be bailing out any of these
people what's the root of the problem
here and again I want to hear from you I
understand that people on both sides are
compassionate the root of the problem is
telling kids who have no idea what they
want to do with their lives to make the
biggest financial decision of their
future before they have any real world
experience claim that this is what is
required right now in the modern
workplace and to have self-esteem or
also by the way tying up children tying
up young people's self-worth with the
degree they have with a sheet of paper
to tell people how important they are
and then promising that we are going to
bail them out it doesn't work it has not
worked it will not work the solution is
not to bail people out the solution is
that everybody start taking personal
responsibility and making better
decisions for yourself what is that let
me go through it one more time okay
don't waste money going to an expensive
university if you don't have to don't
get a useless degree and finish if you
do go to school congratulations I just
saved you 1.4 trillion dollars in a
national bailout we're gonna have Ben
Shapiro in a little bit and one last
thing people wanted us to talk about the
coronavirus yeah I think this is like
Ebola and swine flu it's been blown out
of proportion a little bit one thing too
aware of is of course that um you may
not know you have it until the symptoms
have already manifested themselves with
coronavirus and um
Oh
[Music]
begone with the tow house
I got
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are positively sinister and
delicious guerrilla warfare I'm not
saying the Republic doesn't need to be
fixed but life does a guy have to be
wearing this stupid helmet jiu-jitsu is
such a powerful thing in every aspect of
your life it really does improve the way
that you think and improves your
confidence and proves your physical
conditioning it improves the way you
view other people and the world it just
can have such a massive impact it's had
a huge impact on my life as far as kids
go I say that jiu-jitsu is more
important for children then love is
[Music]
no no no no wait are you gonna shoot me
now I brought you some black rifle
coffee and I want you to give me your
genuine honest reaction to it okay I did
not consent to this experiment however
seeing is this would be a horrible waste
of coffee that has already gone to the
complex process of being brewed as well
as sourced and roasted which most do not
appreciate I feel obligated to conduct a
formal cupping but I don't think you're
gonna like how this one ends up
[Music]
[Music]
it was alright black rifle coffee black
rifle coffee dot-com flash Crider say I
had to do like multiple takes because I
kept saying black rifle that calm slash
Crowder because around the office we
just said we just refer to as black
rifle we're on a to name only basis
where that familiar black rifle coffee
calms slash Crowder you get 20% off your
first order this is my favorite we just
we refer to this as the medic blend here
in the office but it's actually I think
called the the coffee saves or vintage
roast we have a espresso machine at the
office that's what we put in there it is
as good as any coffee we've put through
it and we've put through at least
probably 20-30 varietals so yeah they're
a veteran owned company a portion of the
profits go to support veteran causes
that's all great their coffee though is
better than the competition and a more
reasonable price we're going to do some
coffee tutorials coming here in the
future but black rifle coffee comm slash
Crowder if you're gonna drink coffee
support a company that has the balls to
support this show and they make better
coffee it's a win-win for your
consideration for Best Actor in a
supporting role Gilbert Godfrey in 12
years a slave
[Music]
[Music]
well the second though I don't stick up
in home alone so this is a stick-up
Toy Story Toy Story alone thinking Buzz
Lightyear but this is a stick-up that's
all home alone that's all but Toy Story
what's going on what's happened
connecting those two I should be running
should be running the Democratic primary
very much like I should be eating a
funnel cake I have a question for our
next guest is not politically related
all we were talking about it during the
break but I want to clarify that you
know him
some of you love them some of you don't
that's the nature of the beast you can
follow them at ben shapiro on the
Twitter of course daily wire.com I
believe the term is editor-in-chief he
can correct me on that his show is the
Ben Shapiro show mr. Shapiro how are you
sir I'm doing okay or at least I was
until I got here so I appreciate that
you know you always plays it coy he does
but that off air he sends me wildly
uncomfortable pictures nothing like he's
looking for love in all the wrong places
right all the wrong places yeah I don't
know whether you want pictures of Chuck
Schumer not I mean no idea unsolicited
that's what he calls it
Chuck let me ask you this so poem and
I've been using this on a show where a
few people have said where did you get
this where did you learn yet ish but
poem means face and if it's but you were
telling me that that doesn't actually
mean face in Hebrew which I'm very
confused as to what Yiddish is exactly
right so yeah this is sort of a mash-up
it's sort of like Ladino like there are
a few languages that are sort of mashups
of other languages and you dishes a
mash-up of Hebrew and Aramaic there's
some Slavic languages in there and
because the Jews are you know kind of
kicked around to various countries there
are constantly words that are being
added that are sort of adoptions from
other from other languages but punim is
basically just a different pronunciation
of Ponemah which if you read the Bible
and it refers to you know like the face
of Moses it's referred to as Ponemah
honey honey is how it's pronounced in
Hebrews pronounced punim in yiddish okay
my order Haim SOG from little Mumbai
Grill all the time I don't know that's
the thing with Indian restaurants I feel
like it's a different I feel two
different things I don't know what aloo
Gobi paneer is
that's what really and you that didn't
Los Angeles I think one time we went to
a restaurant and it was one of those
affected menus was like oh I have
cracked quail egg and ever to the table
acted like well I'll have another one of
those as though we ever eat this way
these foodie restaurants all right this
is a completely off the beaten path here
impeachment your thoughts boring okay
boring I mean it's it's it's incredibly
boring we all know where this is going
and watching the media tried to spin it
into a frenzy I said on my show I mean
it's it's it's like trying to watch the
media spin people up for female
Ghostbusters right guys guaranteed this
is the greatest movie and if you don't
love the movie it's just because you
hate women and because you're a member
of toxic fandoms and now all of America
is toxic fandom when it comes to
impeachment because you can pull people
on what they think but people will give
you an opinion on anything you pull them
on right if you ask them if they'd like
to color blue and they will give you an
opinion that does not mean they spend
every waking moment consumed with the
question of whether blue is a nice color
or not well why'd you say yes color Ben
I know I'm sorry I didn't mean to offend
you of colle and mean to offend you with
my with my gender specific colors but
but the fact that it the fact that there
are so many people in the media who are
just over the moon about this as though
something new is going to come from it
is ridiculous now that said it's like
everybody blew this thing everybody as
for a usual arrangement in American
politics ever its veep it's not house of
cards everybody's an idiot so on the one
hand you have the Democrats who push
forward an impeachment without any
witnesses that actually testify as to
what would be the impeachable offense
they put forward impeachment offenses
that don't include criminal offenses
which would be the first time in
American history that you have like no
criminal offenses whatsoever alleged
that would be kind of a new one but they
do a second debate Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton the the crime there was perjury
it wasn't sex with an intern was perjury
a lot of people miss it like oh he had a
little bit of fun this is way worse
right
perjury is an actual crime which of
course is something I think that you
actually talked about I want to touch
unless you said that it might be a
problem as far as Bolton if Bolden comes
to testify or if he's forced to testify
and if Donald Trump did there could be a
risk of committing perjury at that point
right you never want Trump to testify
under any circumstance if your Trump's
lawyers chained them up in the basement
you put on pornography and you just say
never exit like yeah there's
no hey wait why would there be
pornography Nesta baseba have you even
watch did you watch seven before this
you've been watching seven I mean I'm
not gonna tell you whether it was like
pornographic version of saw but it yeah
you went from house of cards and this I
think you have Kevin Spacey on the brain
seven that's the seven degrees I mean
Kevin Bacon certainly hope not but in
any case veterans may see on the brain
that well we're not gonna go there in
any case the the the problem here for
the Democrats is of course they rush
this thing they didn't bother to wait
for the witnesses they didn't bother to
go through the entire process and then
they get to the Senate and the
Republicans have a fairly good case for
saying okay we're not gonna do your work
for you right you guys didn't call the
witnesses you didn't wait you didn't do
any of this stuff so we're not gonna
call your witnesses for you we're just
gonna look at what you gave us and we're
gonna say no and then that's gonna be
end of this and then precedent from
decides that he is his own best defense
attorney and this is the biggest problem
right the the reason Trump can't get a
good defense attorney is because what
good defense attorney in their right
mind would defend this client it's like
like as it as an attorney their first
rule to your client is you get them in a
room you say shut up just shut shut it
didn't just be quiet
yeah and Trump because he will not do
that instead he's constantly blowing up
his own defense attorneys case so the
best possible defense for Trump from the
beginning was yes I said to the
Ukrainians that unless they did a series
of investigation surrounding 2016 about
which I have concerns as it turns out
some justified some not so justified but
I have concerns and I want all those
investigated in return for the aid right
and that's not wrong right that's not
impeachable you may not like it you may
not like my judgment you may think I'm
buying into Rudi's conspiracy theories
but it has nothing to do with getting
Joe Biden out for 20/20 or anything
right it's that I'm hearing all this
crap about what's going on in Ukraine
and I want all of it investigate and
then you get your money right and that's
not impeachable if he had said that
we're done already
because then john bolton comes forward
and he says right you know what Trump
told me he told me if he wanted to
condition military aid and all these
investigation and Trump is like right so
and then we don't have to call Bolton
cuz Bobo doesn't have anything to add to
the story instead what Trump does is Jen
buttons a liar is it damn sure that
Trump actually did that considering that
the money was delivered before you know
the deadline
I mean condition the mill that he
conditioned the military aid on some
form of Investigations I think it's
fairly certain that he did that I mean
he he hints at
in the in 25 in the July 25th phone call
he doesn't explicitly say in the July
25th phone call he that there's multiple
people testifying at this point that he
has told people who have told them that
the two things are conditional Bolden is
now saying overtly that this is the case
and Trump has provided no other
explanation as to why the military aid
was was held up in the first place like
normally if you're going to give another
explanation it's why the military aid
was held up you should actually just say
it right right and it doesn't and it
doesn't hold for him to say well you
know we don't pay our fair we pay too
much of their Ukrainian military burden
that's been true for years right what
happened in the timeline I think like
you delineate between impeachable
offenses you know actual crimes or
something you may not like I think it's
also important to delineate as you've
said John Donald Trump shoots from the
hip there's a difference between a
conversation with you know I'd like for
you to look into that that Biden kid
Abishag does it speak Ukrainian he has
no experience really guess I just wish
there's a difference between that and
officially withholding funds and
particularly if it were past the
deadline and agreed-upon deadline that
would be more of a problem so I do think
we don't know yet whether it was
anything official or just him talking
and I think that's kind of the risk like
you said the waters are muddy to you but
do you think there is let me ask you
this do you think there is some value in
Donald Trump not following the PlayBook
kind of like with the election because
there is a court obviously a court of
law and there's a court of public
opinion and regardless let's say his
name is cleared he hasn't done anything
wrong
as you've alluded to it doesn't matter
if the public like Donald Don Lemon all
of these people have been tearing his
name forever so there is some value
there to fighting back in the in the
sphere of public opinion we think well I
see here's the thing I think you can do
both meaning I think that as you know
playing defense attorney for Trump what
you want is for him to make a case that
is factually based and defensible and
the reason you want to be factually
based as well as defensible and not just
sort of defensible but not factually
based is because now you've opened the
door to all this testimony right you've
now created the situation where let's
let's be real about this Republicans
don't just need Trump to win in 2020
they need to retain the Senate right a
bunch of senators in purple states what
is bad for those senators in purple
states as if it looks as though there
was a very material witness and then
they were complicit in rejecting those
witnesses and then this thing goes
forward right we they acquit him this
thing goes forward two weeks before the
election you get a bunch of people who
are out there saying I was withheld
here's all my new
bombshell material it drops a week and a
half before the election and that pseudo
bombshell which really isn't a bombshell
but that the media will play it that way
yeah that hurts Trump what you actually
want is to get the decks clear anyway
though I mean we know like at least Rick
Wilson's gonna release a book or
something there'll be a few of those
bombshells no matter what that's true
but you want but but what you don't want
is to be the person who was caught out
as saying I explicitly said I don't want
these people testifying and then that
exact person comes out two weeks before
the election and then says right I
wanted to testify the Republicans
stopped me and now the senator is in
trouble is anything for Trump right this
is for a lot of the Senators you don't
want to put the senators in a position
where they have to defend why they were
covering for Trump when honestly he's
gonna quit it anyway right what you
would like to do is be able to say
listen you guys wanted Bolton we gave
you a Bolton Bolton came in he said his
piece that wasn't impeachable we moved
to acquit and him story right that's
that to me that is a smarter strategy
you want to give your people ground to
fight for short again listen I'm not
saying Trump can't defend himself I'm
saying that Donald Trump so far in this
investigation has suggested he didn't
know left harness and then left harness
drops the table he's explicitly talking
about Murray Ivanovitch right Trump has
suggested that the perfect phone call
took place it is not a perfect phone
call by any stretch of the imagination
saying perfect that's Donald Trump say
it was a good phone call in his mind
he's gonna it was a good four it was
perfect listen for people who are the
base we're gonna vote for him anyway
none of this makes any difference right
and people who hate him
it makes no difference right but for
those seven people who are in between
the fact is you want to make it easier
not harder to defend you right through
the goal here I've said before when it
comes to elections there's two goals one
is to make it nearly impossible to vote
for the other guy which Trump is great
at and the other is to make it really
easy for people to support you right
right and Trump is not so great at the
making it very easy for people to
support him he makes it easy for people
who support him to love him but he
doesn't make it really easy for people
who are on the fence to support it I
agree that would agree with you on that
front and yeah it's amazing if people
are undecided now but I do think policy
wise and this isn't that we've been
talking about a little bit behind the
scenes and maybe will released a segment
on this policy-wise there is no choice
for conservatives like I see people who
are in point in the never Trump camp but
what bothers me is it's predicates on
this idea that because of my
conservative principles from a long time
I'm and I see people coming out saying I
will vote for the DNC am it well Hall
second well that's insane patently
insane right I'm somebody who didn't
vote for Trump in 2016 it's patently
insane to suggest at this point that
given Trump's policy record and given
what the Democrats are putting up on the
other side
you'd be voting for a Democrat in order
to uphold the merits of the Constitution
or some such nonsense about today but
there could be she would overthrow the
First Amendment yes but there are quite
a few people who are in that camp and I
think they're like five of them I think
I mean I think there is wildly overblown
I think that that is I think it's a
Bugaboo and a lot of people in team
Trump like to use the sort of the
whipping boy for this for this
particular election if frump loses the
election it's not gonna be because seven
people including Rick Wilson we're like
we ran an ad about Trump okay it's not
gonna because of that if you lose this
to Bernie Sanders like try and blame
anybody Sanders I don't think they
realize that you're doing the Rick
Wilson face without do it like you're
manifesting yourself like honestly like
who is the constituency for Rick Wilson
it's the people who watch CNN and MSNBC
I mean those are the people who are who
are paying his salary these days so
French Stewart's would like him I feel
makes a lot of sense
French Stewart you're still around well
now I've met Rick Wilson's fan like I
just I think that the question for Trump
is gonna be and increasingly is gonna be
if you if he loses to somebody like
Bernie Sanders I don't know how you pin
that on the on the 7 never Trump pers
weren't like true never Trump errs who
are left like that's gonna like Bernie
Sanders is well I think there's some
responsibilities because these people
get so much airtime like we saw with Don
Lemon right so maybe a very small
contingency but it listen I don't mean I
mean it absolves them of responsibility
for making dumb points and mocking
people ridiculously and making fools of
themselves I mean you always bear
responsibility for what you say no i
don't but i think it does i think
something that is important like you
said like you've said here his base are
going to vote for him anyway but for the
people who are undecided people who may
be somewhat republican or maybe moderate
and not necessarily be political
hobbyists as as you are into a lesser
degree myself you know impeachment is
what the democrats wanted that is a
really really loaded word so they can go
out and say that and so I do think that
since we're past that point that's kind
of a bridge too far I understand we were
saying strategically there need to be
some some calculated decisions but I do
think there's some value here in in
burning this thing down since
impeachment has already happened that's
what they wanted that was really the
only goal here and they're just sort of
treading water I I do think there's
value it at some point now not giving
another inch I don't know the best way
listen I hear that argument I really do
I'm not I'm not saying that it's a
completely foolish argument I'm not
ripping into it and saying like
everybody's doing or anything I'm just
saying that I think there's a fairly
good strategic argument for allowing
senators to at least create a defensive
shield for themselves sure in case one
of these witnesses comes forward later
and they say okay well I didn't vote to
ban the witness right I said that the
witness could testify they testified and
we heard what they had to say and now
it's all off the deck right I mean now
now that Emma cops are gonna say what
they're gonna say there's nothing new to
break on impeachment in the same way
that you know there are a lot of people
urging Trump just fire mulher right just
get rid of it because we know what this
is it's a setup the Democrats want you
they want after you and I was saying the
whole time just let it go forward go all
the way to the investigation will get to
the end there's not gonna be a lot there
and then Trump will be able to claim
vindication that's what happens what I'm
saying here is that it would be better
to do that over the next couple of weeks
and it would be too precipitously just
nuke the thing and then right two weeks
out from the election new information
arises I was after Muller no matter what
new information arising like right and
we let you do the whole thing you spent
years doing it millions of dollars you
didn't come up with what you wanted and
I just pissed about it better to do that
than appear as obstructionist because
that does have right now something like
70% of Americans say they want for their
witnesses again does that mean they're
passionate about it they're desperate
for no but doesn't mean that if you are
a senator like I know we all don't like
Susan Collins but we would like to
retain a Republican in that seat sure if
you're a senator like Susan Collins
you're running a very narrow race you
know honestly like calling the witness
to to make sure that we retain a
Republican majority and the Senate seems
like not a terrible idea to me yes and I
would agree with you on all those fronts
except for the fact that we are still
talking about a general American public
who actually believe my god Christine
Blasi Ford's claims because the media
moves on so they would have claimed the
investigation we're talking about Muller
a victory then moved on you know same
thing that no one know this is a real
most people have no idea that half of
the cabinet you just just recanted the
immediate just moves on so I do think
that that is something to take into
account there is this unholy amalgam of
media and DC that we haven't dealt with
before of course I agree I agree with
all of that I just I don't love the
logic that since everybody sucks it's
not in our hands anyway so nougat okay
Ben Shapiro
hold that thought Daly wired.com we are
about to go overtime we have Ben Shapiro
on hold for those who want to see the
rest of the interview I think we're
going to talk askers more
with been good a lot of credit calm /
mug club you can watch the full
interview full show at Blais TV we'll be
right back after this sorry bad notice
yeah he keeps on whipping into any crud
[Music]
what's your home defense plan when it
comes to safety there's no substitute
for a quality firearm and if you're a
gun owner there's no replacement for
firearms legal protection firearms legal
protection provides lawful gun owners an
uncapped legal defense program 24/7
emergency hotline access to a network of
over 2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
via our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense and visit
firearm legal comm lwc today
let's um go to the merge shot let's all
go to the merge shot
let's all go to the merge shop buy
ourselves some sweaty snazzy clothing
and swag divide louder with crowded shop
calm like this new signature baseball
tee for these Ranger panties or of
course the Holy Grail itself mug Club
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was called the revisiting the Greg
Louganis stance Oh Val may not remember
it by the way accent an interview of ben
shapiro you only know this because you
watched the show I guarantee it was 100
wiring to you that you're your niche of
study was not gay divers who filled the
Olympic pool with AIDS I'm proud of it
for people who don't know Greg Louganis
he was a diver hey you ever tried that
where you dive off by the way web extent
agree with ben shapiro I can't we're not
mud climbers you cannot swim okay let me
ask you a real quick yes way I'm okay
because a lot of you only think we're
joking about this it would like raise
your dad obviously looks pretty sure
looks far more black than you do and
it's true other relatives who are who
are oh yeah butterfl Mike what's the
Swimming's do they dab they did they
learn to swim later I have a couple that
cannot swim at all really yeah so no I
don't know why yeah it's a little bit I
guess it's a cultural thing my dad
actually doesn't like water at all we
doesn't like he doesn't like any of us
to be around water he just has like a
fear of it some reason why I mean I'm
just like a deep-seated thing I'm
learning so much about your father is
afraid of water and your relatives who
do not swim that is exceed this is a
cultural thing audio wait do you know
anyone in your direct family who is not
capable of swimming as a grown adult no
no I don't know it'd be a rare no like
if there would be someone at a pool
party or let's say to barbecue and there
was just one white guy you're like oh no
that's that's a Edie he can't swim but
he's 28
no again swim oh yeah we took my brother
my adopted brother and he's he's black
we took him on a canoe trip and he had
the like the waders on and everything
and then I'm not I'm not
yeah okay one minute off of push off of
the side they flipped the boat and he's
he's panicking like stand up stand up oh
he just stands up dude
well I've told the story before we're
about certain death tipping over in a
kayak and one of those oldies it wasn't
open oh no no he was out you get out he
was just floating there was an open
faced canoes so it was just you know he
just needed someone to teach him how to
swim
these are interesting things I don't are
we are we supposed to be colorblind are
we supposed to be sweet
swim disabled blind I mean it sticks out
to us and by the way on the flip side it
also sticks out to us that young black
kids far faster than young white kids
that's true they were deep when I was a
go to the local mall I was in st. Clair
Shores when we lived in Michigan and I'd
be walking you know about two and a half
oh if it's my mouth and the kids be
deccan me out and they'd be faking me
and they'd be chicken and driving our
kid no I'm just white I was not nearly
as physically complicated but they still
wear floaties that's true so it evens
out that's my point there's a laia
budget and no one is better growers no
other we just have different strengths
I'm a pretty good swimmer
lest you think that point one percent
sub-saharan African from my twenty three
in me might make it a challenge it is
not I break down the racial barriers
okay all right so I do want to talk
about we talked about this a little bit
earlier and I sent out this tweet about
you don't buy a new car ever and some
people got really upset about it some
people would tweet me back say well I
bought a new car and it's it's way less
maintenance and better mileage come on
you can buy a used Fiesta right you
don't need to get a new Prius with two
giant non recyclable batteries but I
didn't have this conversation recently
with someone who was a friend of mine
who's had some trouble with that not
trouble but it hasn't been super
responsible finances and I talked to him
about the idea of buying a new car
versus used car he'd purchase a new car
and when I explained to him the
depreciation and I explained to him why
it's not a good investment why a car
actually is not an investment at all
it's a depreciating asset he actually
said that
Wow I can't believe that I didn't know
this and it was very helpful for him and
this is something that I want to get to
all of us have an area I'm not saying
I'm an expert in finance at all but this
was just imparting some wisdom that no
one had ever even attempted to was
someone like this I think a lot of you
out there probably know that old adage
that you shouldn't be buying a new car
depreciates 30% when you roll it off a
lot but a lot of the time we have we
have this knowledge that we keep to
ourselves and we may not even realize
that we are doing it there there's there
are multitude of ways that we can help
those around us directly and I think
it's a super important for people to
think about because as conservatives as
small government for enterprisers
we don't want the government coming in
and solving our problems that means that
we need to take more personal
responsibility and be more compassionate
be more helpful to those around us and
something that I have learned in being
around some of the best in their field
on this show and even whether you like
them or not but we've had ok George st.
Pierre the best Daniel Cormier is been
on the show multiple times the best
Bryan Shaw five times world Strongest
Man the best we've had a Thomas soul the
best as far as writing something that I
have noticed with people who are very
good at something accomplished people
typically not always but accomplished
people help other people accomplish in
other words when I talk with these
people off air and I say man how do you
how do you do that or how do you hit
that low single when I was talking with
one of the fighters oh man I'll show you
they get excited at teaching people
something at helping somebody man how do
you learn - how do you learn to do
research that way oh let me show you how
I do it it's actually a process that's
pretty simple I've run into this
consistently people who are accomplished
are not only willing but often
enthusiastic about and looking for
people to request their assistance in
accomplishing accomplished people help
people accomplish and I say this also in
the general sense I don't just mean
someone who's accomplished you know we
have professional athletes or Pulitzer
winners here on this show I do mean this
in the general sense if you are
accomplished in any area it is your duty
to share it I don't mean be a
know-it-all but I mean if you know that
you could help someone with some advice
if you could help them with with it with
some coaching I don't know what it is if
you if you find something that you
believe is a gift that has improved your
life you can even be as simple as that
something that's improved your life and
you know what improve the lives of
others it is your duty to share it it's
your duty to impart wisdom so people
often wonder I get this request on why
do you talk about I talked about
jiu-jitsu a lot in the show or another
want the film the edge I've talked about
it quite a bit well let me explain to
you why not only because it's something
that I know but with Brazilian jiu-jitsu
that I've been doing for a long time I
started when I was a kid um when I
learned it I had spent years doing
things that didn't work I was bullied
got my ass kicked as a kid I
to the karate schools and the kungfu in
the Krav Maga and the ball shot
self-defense at the YMCA we all know
that stuff doesn't work okay then when I
learned basic judo which is what I
started with with a communist Romanian
instructor it was great he was a great
great competitor but we just avoided
talking about the Eastern Bloc when I
learned from him I applied it and it
worked right away and the reason I talk
about this quite a bit is because I
remember that experience where I went
whoa what what is this all this time why
doesn't everybody know this I went down
to the made-up martial art where some
guy at the community center called it
icuk a jujitsu dough
so he could give himself a ninth degree
black belt and I wasted money and years
of my life and there's this is so simple
I've learned it in six months and it
works why doesn't everybody know this
why isn't everybody aware of the bullet
that's out there that's why I talk about
it because it was a revelation for me
and I think it would I would be doing
you a disservice to not talk about it
same thing with my favorite film I
talked about this quite a bit the edge
okay now here's the deal with the edge
Anthony Hopkins Alec Baldwin fantastic
film you saw it audio wave you liked it
you've seen it quarter black hair I've
seen you have seen it okay did you like
it as well yeah yeah
now I'm not saying it's the best film
where it needs to be a favorite I'm not
saying it's Citizen Kane but Citizen
Kane it sounded like I said Kate Loudoun
Kincaid remember that's from Shelby rain
the aliens make the ring chubby name
that movie line and you'll get a free
t-shirt I'm not saying that it's Citizen
Kane I'm not even saying that it's
Chinatown which is a better film than
Godfather again I say that because
everyone loves to praise Godfather I
think it will help you for me to make
you aware of which film was better but I
do tell people this when people ask why
I'm so enthusiastic about the edge go
watch the edge by David Mamet who's also
a conservative who wasn't at the time
when he wrote it
and aside from one portion of green
screen in that film and I was because
they used an actual bear and shot it
pragmatically but there was one scene
that was pretty difficult to do so
there's one scene where okay I'll grant
you it looks a little bit chancy you can
see the green screen but outside of that
because I know I'll get comments on that
find me one fault with that film that's
not the film that I would say on paper
oh my gosh this is a technical wonder
but it is so
good and nobody talks about it that's
why I talk about it I remember when I
bought the DVD was in a bargain bin I
was in Toronto with my father on a
business trip we had just seemed chicken
run at the movie theater and then I saw
the edge and a bargain bin for $4.99 my
dad said that was pretty good I saw that
with your mom he knew that I liked the
Anthony Hopkins so I said okay I'll buy
it I put it I popped it in actually it's
might have been a VHS back then popped
it and watched it and when it finished I
said why isn't everybody talking about
this film why doesn't everybody know
it's such a good film and nobody lists
it and the recommendations and if you
know anyone who's seen the film and you
ask them about it like oh yeah that was
a good movie the same principle here
applies to how all of us have something
and it may not be the edge it may not be
person you Jitsu but something that has
dramatically improved our lives now I've
talked myself of course Christ God my
faith family that's why I talk about it
that's why Christians often they're
blamed for for proselytizing I like
Christians or I like people who are
religious just not when they're preachy
well here's the thing they're sharing it
because it's improved their life
immeasurably more than any other
decision that they've made you may not
agree with them you may not find
yourself being a person of faith but I
don't understand how we can blame people
for that even if someone wants to
convert me to I don't know what it is to
hoe as witnesses it could be Mormonism
it could be Scientology I've had people
come on and do that and guess what I
appreciate it because they feel that
it's improved their life and then I can
be the judge as to whether or not that's
accurate
now one thing when I when I tell you
this I'm not talking about going out
there when I'm saying sharing and impart
wisdom I'm talking about being judgey
I'm not talking about telling everybody
what their what they're doing wrong and
looking for an opportunity to scold
because there are some people like that
I've had them in my Bible study and I
immediately kicked them out even though
I don't run the Bible study they're
usually quite pissed but again this is
why people share their faith this is why
I talk about jiu-jitsu what's his white
talk about films like the engine this is
what I want you to do I want you to
think about what it is that has improved
your life wherever you are right now
take a minute think about it think about
something that maybe you sort of think
of as this I guess open secret for lack
of a better word take a second pause
this if you have to if you're listening
on audio
congratulations you are a miracle
because everyone mostly watches us on
YouTube but I hope you're pausing and
listening if you're in your car keep
your eyes on the road whatever it is for
you by the way I want to see your
comment comment let me know what it is
what has improved your life so
dramatically so monumentally that it's
altered the course of who you are and
it's something that a lot of people
don't know about or maybe it's just
something that somebody you know who's
in your personal circle of friends
doesn't know about like somebody buying
a new car when they're there strange for
cash what is it think about it what does
improve your life what do you know that
somebody in your life does not know how
can you help someone what is your secret
what's your rush more max then it's your
duty to share it this week go out share
it with at least three people this is
how we start the fix to student loans to
fatherless households to the economic
problems that we face in this country
division it all starts with helping
folks that you know if you know
something and it can help people it is
your responsibility to share it let me
know how it works out I want to see a
bunch of you in the comment section
alright I'll see you next week but not
Thursday on Sunday February 9th because
of the Oscar lives
[Music]